il y un peu plus d'un an cet hôpital
n'existait pas l'immeuble était
désaffecté ong viva rio alors été
engagée par la mairie de niteroi ville
voisine de rio de janeiro pour en faire
un centre d'urgence réservé aux cas les
plus sévères de co vide
pourquoi vivario pour une administration
plus petites plus efficaces aussi
l'agilité parce que c'est ça fait passer
dans une vitesse impressionnante
on a construit les conditions formelles
hôpital de 1,2 à moi et puis on a
commencé déjà et de plus maintenant elle
va s'évader venez en hôpital permanent
dans la danse et pour cette région
l'hôpital océaniques au compte 136 lee
viva rio a obtenu également après
soumission la gestion de neuf unités
d'urgence à rio ici à niteroi
c'est le bout de la ligne des soins sur
la grille de la façade des rubans de
toutes les couleurs ce sont des
guérisons de l'aco vide chaque sortie en
soi est une fête avec klaas knot font la
fête
j'ai vaincu coville là c'est une gaine
lutte contre le coc vite et chaque
personne que ce soit de l'hôpital el
hadji vainqueur sur l'un des rubans le
chiffre 1000 milles guérison sur 1600
hospitalisation des cas les plus
mortelles dans l'hôpital océanique
on a eu un bon résultat plus ou moins 30
poussins déjà clientes dans les niveaux
intensif sorte top 5 1%
bien sûr il n'entre pas que des
ambulances ici la petite église en face
offre ses prières aux familles des
victimes de l'aco vide et aux personnels
de santé dans cette pandémie viva rio
s'est chargé aussi de pallier une
certaine famine dans les favelas surtout
le manque d'emploi fait des ravages
on travaille sur une carte
d'alimentation cinq minutes oui d'un
4-5-1 communauté favela
on a commencé par neuf avec l'appui du
canada
oui et ça a commencé à rouler comme ça
et ça a été un mouvement des soldats
étaient impressionnants de l'épée
peut-être les plus impressionnants qu'on
a et d'un autre histoire
cette montée des soldats étaient toutes
côté au niveau des élites met aussi au
niveau populaire célèbre casaque ces
aides entre le système de santé
brésilien est universel et gratuit avec
des hôpitaux bien équipée qui ont
répondu relativement bien la crise de
l'aco vide mais il a souffert du manque
de coordination nationale et des
déclarations contradictoires du
gouvernement du gerb also know la
politisation de la et pv mais dans un
contexte grave
à quel point la gestion de la pandémie
par le gouvernement de jaillir ball
sonar ou est-elle criminel ou pas c'est
ce que va tenter d'établir la cpi la
commission parlementaire d'enquêté mais
en politisant davantage la pandémie ne
risque-t-on pas de détourner l'attention
de la gravité de l'aco vide de son
variant brésiliens et des besoins en
vaccins
jean michel leprince radio canada rio de
janeiro